es geht um rock wann das ist in gewisser
weise ein spin off der großen star wars
saga die welt gerät aus den fugen
imperiale flaggen beherrschen die
galaxis
wir befinden uns zwischen den episoden
drei und vier
und im endeffekt werden alle diejenigen
die überhaupt den ersten chronologisch
ersten star wars filmen also krieg der
sterne jemals gesehen haben genau wissen
was passiert denn wir bekommen die
vorgeschichte dazu erzählt name fürs
protokoll
jennifer fälschung imperialer dokumente
besitz gestohlener güter schwerer
körperverletzung und widerstand gegen
die verhaftung auf sich allein gestellt
sie den 15
rücksichtslos aggressiv und
undiszipliniert das ist doch ein
rebellion oder
ich rebelliere führt eine neue weibliche
hauptperson 1
die alter von nach vielleicht fünf sechs
jahre in ihrer mutter verliert die klar
ermordet wird ihr vater wird verschleppt
und der vater ist das mastermind hinter
der konstruktion des todes sterbe und
will aber gleichzeitig nicht dass dieses
werk tatsächlich dazu genutzt wird
andere welten zu zerstören und baut
darum eine fehlstelle mit rein
ein text einer bedeutenden waffe steht
bevor
wir müssen wissen wie man sie zerstört
im endeffekt dreht sich der ganze film
nur darum wie man im besitz dieser
information kommt wie man den todesstern
zerstören kann
was wir kennen es die optik also das
sind wieder die typischen wüstenplaneten
und manchmal auch andere sehr
fantastische welten in denen sich das
abspielt straßenszenen mit erstaunlichen
kreaturen die nebeneinander herlaufen
und was wir kennen es die typische
bemühung dem todesstern zu zerstören
daran hat sich selbst eine zwischen
episoden nichts geändert
es ist etwas was man mit einer gewissen
liebe zum detail betrachten kann
weil einfach eine lücke im erzähl conti
forum geschlossen wird aber andererseits
keine über die man sich jemals vorher
gedanken gemacht hätte haben
frühwarnsysteme und patrouille
geschwader bewusste kennen bleiben ganz
tiefen
26 prozentige wahrscheinlichkeit zu
versuchen wie weit noch ich weiß nicht
wieso gute nämlich normalerweise nicht
aber diese nah dran jetzt 5 was man
gerne sieht das muss man sagen sind die
schauspieler das ist mal nicht übermäßig
prominent besetzt also einen richtigen
stars spielt eigentlich nur mikkelsen
und vielleicht noch mit einschränkungen
ben mendelsohn mit der einen großartigen
show gespielt und dann gibt's die
hauptdarstellerin felicity jones die s
klasse
aber das ist noch kein richtig großer
star wenn sich das durch den film endet
dann hat er doch noch seine berechtigung
[Musik]
hieraus ein star wars liebhabern
uneingeschränkt empfohlen nicht dass die
besonders viel lernen werden aber die
werden ihre freude haben alle anderen
öffentlichen finanzen keinen fall
anzusehen denn wenn bereits weg ist dass
man weiß wieder rahmen um diesen film
herum ist dann geht auch eine menge von
der substanz folge glückwunsch du wirst
gerade gerettet
bitte leiste keinen widerständen
[Musik]